-Welcome back, everybody.
We're here with Bobby Flay!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Brasserie B opening up
in Caesars Palace in December.
You're gonna make
something off that menu.
This is a pork chop
you're going to teach Quest?
-Yeah, so we're making --
So, as you know,
we like french fries.
-Yeah.
-And so we're gonna make
pork frite.
So we're gonna do a pork chop
with french fries.
We're gonna start
with some spice rub.
You guys are gonna both do this,
okay?
-Okay.
-All right. So, take the spices
and put them in the bowl
and mix them up.
-Yeah.
-So we have some --
some mustard seed,
we have some some red chilies,
we have coriander, paprika.
Just throw it all in there,
and you're gonna season this
with a little salt and pepper,
as well.
[ Laughter ]
And then just season one side
with the -- with the --
with the spice rub.
-All right. So, yeah,
just throw that on there.
-Yeah. Just -- yeah.
Rub it in. Exactly.
Okay. Then we're gonna take
your pork chop,
and we're gonna put it
right into the -- into the pan.
-Ooh. What kind of oil
you got there?
Grapeseed.
-This is avocado oil.
-Avocado, There you go.
-Good guess, though.
-Thank you, thank you.
Yeah, appreciate it.
-Do you cook
with grapeseed oil?
-No.
[ Laughter ]
-You know what?
-No, I just drink it.
-Wait a second.
You thought about lying about it
for a second.
You like grapeseed oil?
"Yes, exactly.
I love that vinaigrette I make."
Exactly.
-So this is avocado oil.
-Yes, avocado oil.
Very nice light oil.
I kind of went away from
the canola oil a little bit.
I just -- you know,
they say it's better for you.
I don't know.
-Oh, is that right?
-Yeah. Okay.
I didn't finish
my book, "Fit," by Bobby Flay.
-Exactly, exactly.
[ Laughter ]
-No spoilers.
-Exactly.
-So you only put on one side.
Why not the other side?
-Well, only --
only on one side
'cause I still want
to taste the pork and --
but I do want the spices
to enhance the pork itself.
Give it a little flavor.
So the spice rub
is doing two things.
It's actually, obviously,
creating flavor,
but it's also becoming
part of the pork.
It's gonna help form
a crust on the outside.
-All right I like this.
Quest, you have
any questions so far?
-Uh...
When do we eat?
[ Laughter ]
-All right, that's good.
-All right. So you can see
you get a really nice
spice rib in there.
-Oh, yeah. Look at that.
Now, I can never make it look
like that if I do it.
-You can't?
-No.
-What do you mean?
-I don't know. I just --
You're a pro at this.
-So we're gonna --
we're gonna put these in the
oven for about 7 or 8 minutes,
just until they cook through.
-Yep.
-Okay?
-Perfect.
All right.
We're gonna leave
that pan up there.
And then you guys can bring up
your pork, okay?
And I'm gonna make the pan sauce
that goes in here.
-Okay.
So we have a little fresh ginger
that goes right
into the same pan,
a little bit of honey.
-Yep. Honey.
-Some orange juice.
-Ooh.
-Whoa.
-Oh, yeah.
-Orange juice.
-Ginger, orange juice,
and honey.
This is if you have a cough.
If you have a cough or a cold.
-And this is Calvados.
You know what Calvados is?
-Avocado oil?
-Yes, exactly.
No, it's actually --
it's like an apple liqueur.
So, you know,
pork chops, apples.
-Oh, wow.
-Old school. Okay?
So we're gonna add
a little Calvados to this.
And then we're going
to let it cook down.
And then we're gonna add
a little bit of butter.
-Oh, God.
-A little bit of butter.
And then some pink peppercorns.
-And pink peppercorns.
-Pink -- [ Laughs ]
Yes.
-This is unbelievable.
I like all this stuff.
I have all this stuff in my --
in my cupboard.
-And then a little...
[ Laughter ]
a little extra butter
for Julia Child.
-Honey, are you finished
with the Calvados?
[ Laughter ]
-Okay, a little parsley.
And then, Jimmy, you want a
little salt and pepper in here?
-Yep. How about this?
Do that?
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, I like that.
-That's kind of good, right?
-That's very nice.
-Yeah, you shouldn't do that.
-We call that the essence.
-Yeah. The essence.
-Very nice. Beautiful.
-Am I supposed to do the same?
-Yes, absolutely.
Why not?
-Okay.
-No, no, I made that up.
-Right in here, Quest.
-What are we supposed to do?
-Okay. Then you're gonna take --
we're gonna spoon the sauce
right on top.
-Yeah. Look at this.
This is how you do it
like Bobby Flay style.
-This is how you do it.
Okay.
-Come on, now.
-Quest, a little bit of sauce
for you, as well.
-Look at this.
Can you see this?
-And then you have the fries.
So we have the pork and fries.
You can have them on the side.
But in France,
they just serve them
right on the plate like this.
-Yeah, hey.
-And you have the pork frite.
-Ooh la la.
[ Laughter ]
Bobby Flay, everybody.
His new restaurant, Brasserie B,
opens in Caesars Palace
in Las Vegas next month
and "Beat Bobby Flay:
Holiday Throwdown"
premieres Tuesday
on Food Network.
More "Tonight Show"
after the break. Stick around.